[Musique]
le césar du meilleur acteur est attribué
à benoît magimel
et job2day d'un cancer dans les quatre
dernières saisons une existence il
retrouve emmanuelle bercot après la tête
haute qui lui avait valu le césar du
second rôle mais il n'avait jamais pris
nommé en meilleur acteur ça peut manger
ainsi pour coco pour envoyer respar pour
les voleurs et françois cluzet et lui
avec des partenaires dans les petits
mouchoirs et sa suite sélection
mécanique
[Musique]
merci merci merci beaucoup
c'est un grand bonheur c'est un immense
cadeau à ce très très très très heureux
chez pas comment exprimer ce que je
ressens peut-être par un petit pas de
danse
[Musique]
je tiens à remercier évidemment
emmanuelle b recours n'est pas là ce
soir mais
quelle chance de l'avoir rencontré quels
chanceux
d'avoir elles de l'avoir dans ma vie
conseil extraordinaire grâce à elle j'ai
deux jeux des rôles magnifiques des
partitions extraordinaire c'était pas
gagné j'ai pas trop envie de faire ce
film parce que c'est par simple mais a
finalement
voilà c'était un film qui parle de pryor
d'un homme qui est condamné mais c'est
surtout un film sur la vie c'est ça que
j'ai compris finalement
je tiens à la remercier je tiens à
remercier toute l'équipe de ce film
c'est toujours important d'avoir des
journées à votre autour de soi je tiens
à remercier les producteurs aussi venir
valenciennes et françois kraus je
remercie mon agent qui l'a ce soir
si le fait de ses merguez je tiens à
remercier un margaux pelletier ma femme
qui enfin sans elle je serai pas là ce
soir je crois et voilà je t'aime
c'est un immense bonheur voilà j'ai 47
ans cadre 47e cérémonie
c'est ainsi merci à tout le monde merci
pour cette soirée magnifique
et voilà qui règle provisoirement le
différend entre gilles lellouche et
pierre dit n'être donc et nous voici
arrivés au moment du césar qui va
transformer une princesse en reine le